well I think it's kind of hard to say
but a one thing I feel like I do know
this is that that it you know on a good
night it feels the same anywhere you
know and it has nothing to do with
language it's like it's it's kind of
amazing that you can you can go
especially for somebody like me who's
pretty like wordy and his songs I'm
always amazed that that even in places
like you know like Italy where people
shouldn't be able to understand you know
and probably don't understand everything
I'm saying they are just as on a good
night they're just as you know happy you
know and that's that's funny I think
that that's really that's really cool
and it's been a big surprise to me but I
guess that you know you know it should
always feel the same to me you know you
know you should feel kind of sweaty and
happy at the end of a show you know
well it's it's it's you know it's 24
hours a day now you know like you can
you can you know in a lot of ways it's
amazing you can get this you can if you
have a song and you want you want people
to hear it if there's no there's no way
to keep you know you can you the world
can hear it the world could hear it and
you know in the space of time it takes
to upload it you know that's you know
it's there's so many people out there
with music who want to be heard and who
you know who deserve to be heard I think
that with an audience with an audience
like I mean I started with an audience
you know it's been growing over the last
10 years so I'd say that that you know
with with with with me I've been lucky
that I have an audience that I can keep
up with in a number of ways it's also a
matter of like how much do you really
want to know about your favorite artist
or even you know or or or your third
favorite artists you know you don't want
to hear about it too much you know you
want to go to their show you want to you
know spend a night go into the show
maybe go get some dinner beforehand you
know or you want to like listen to like
three or four songs on a record you know
and and and you don't need to hear from
them every day about what's going on you
know so there's a line to tread same
with like Twitter and all this you know
Twitter is another thing you know you
don't need to have this constant
connection all the time I really think
that that that that playing a show is
like is like you know a good show feels
like the length of time you'd stay at a
party you know when to go and you know
when to leave and like don't overstay
your welcome you know so I think that
that queries over a death the digital
the digital world to you know you know
it's it's it's it's constantly evolving
but but it's you know the end is still
the same it's you know it's you know
just just being there a little bit you
know
you